[Music]
it's amazing I mean it's really been ten
years in the making it is a very very
unique film I don't know nobody's ever
done anything like this before you know
you're taking this many disparate
franchises really successful franchises
and combining them all into one movie
into one big finale hey everybody its
charlie we got a whole bunch of huge
Avengers for and Marvel news to break
down you may have heard about the QA
that Joe Russo did about Avengers 4
talking about the trailer the runtime of
the movie plot details I'll break all
that stuff down during this video but we
also got more details on what's going on
with Captain Marvel as well as what's
going on with the future of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe so we'll start with
the Avengers 4 stuff then I'll talk
about all that other stuff you may have
heard about that really cool infinity
war book that they just released that
has all this really cool art and details
like spider-man's black costume that
they cut out of the film the alternate
ending to infinity war with a very
different final battle I'm doing a new
giveaway for that all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
Marvel related comment on the video I'll
name a new winner at the end of this
because there were so many things in all
this I just broke this down top-10 style
so we'll start with number 10
Joe Russo confirms in this big Q&A here
right now it's currently sitting at a
three hour runtime now I don't think
there's any way that Disney is gonna let
the Russos release a three-hour movie
but they did imply that it was going to
be longer than Avengers infinity war so
for all of you who are really down for
extended editions of movies myself
included especially given what they're
trying to wrap up in Avengers 4 it
sounds like we're gonna get as close to
that as possible but they've said
nothing about releasing official
extended editions of the movies on
blu-ray or anything like that 9 he said
right now they're working on the visual
effects laying the score down they're
still editing that won't be done till
like the last week before they're forced
to ship out prints of the film to
theaters all over the world so we can
actually sit down and watch it right now
at least in the United States it's
coming out that first Friday in May but
that was the same situation with
infinity war and they changed the
release date at the last minute so
nothing is set in stone until your asses
in the theater and you're actually
watching the movie
eight he confirmed that the stakes are
even higher which makes you think about
what the title might be and how the
title might imply that the stakes are
higher than infinity war infinity war
sounds so definitive that what title
could you give a movie that would make
it sound even crazier so it's not
official confirmation that the title is
Avengers annihilation or anything like
that he trolled the crap out of the
title reveal so when you're Theory
crafting just think about what title you
could give a movie that would very
simply convey how things are so much
crazier than infinity war there was a
teaser description that I did a video
for a little while ago that also says
that same thing that the stakes are even
higher there's an even greater threat
that the Avengers have to face so his
comments during the Q&A just corroborate
that as if the snap leaves the universe
vulnerable to something even worse
causing more problems than it solves you
have to think about the way they explain
that us during infinity war he's got the
blood of the Eternals in him so he lives
much longer than normal people there was
a comic book that they released earlier
this year where you see him out living
all of Marvel's biggest characters so
one of the problems with someone like
that is that their goals become very
myopic they get stuck in their way so
that's the way the Russos talk about
Thanos and his ideas for the snap the
reason why he's so stuck on it so big
one number seven he says we may or may
not see the trailer before the end of
the calendar year before the calendar
turns from 2018 to 2019 that was the
most supreme trolling that I think that
he's done in a long time so if you see
websites saying we might not get a
trailer till 2019 Kevin Feige revealed a
while ago that we would most definitely
see the trailer before the end of the
year so this is just the Russos sadistic
sense of humor always trust Kevin Feige
regardless of what you hear from the
other directors because Kevin Feige
won't lie to people when people ask
Kevin Feige and he doesn't want to
reveal information he'll either say no
comment or I don't have anything to say
about that so when he says we're gonna
see the trailer before the end of the
year he means we're gonna see the
trailer before the end of the year six
really big plot teaser here one of the
writers of infinity war and Avengers 4
gave this quote talking about
Thanos with the implication of looping
snaps that he would do it over and over
again but 5 here's that actual quote and
it comes from that giant infinity war
book
we're doing the giveaway for right now
so he says the Infinity stones have been
misused by people who didn't understand
their true power and now that the real
master of them Thanos has shown up we
can see what they can actually do the
problem is as you can imagine as you
gain control over these things your
story just goes haywire because why are
there any stakes for the man who can
control time-space reality your mind
your soul and power he can reset time in
the universe as many times as it will
take so number four Infinity Gauntlet
Groundhog's Day situation that he
implies what he's saying is is that
Thanos has the ability to reset the
universe if he feels like the snap as he
intended it didn't have the outcome that
he wanted which you know you have
infinite power of course you can reset
time for the entire universe 3 this gets
into the idea of dr. Strange's true plan
his one and fourteen million chance for
the Avengers to eventually defeat Thanos
lose the battle lose several battles to
win the ultimate war giving Thanos the
time stones that Thanos could start this
cycle of snaps buying the surviving
Avengers time to come together find a
way to use the quantum realm quantum
energy to defeat Thanos and break the
cycle
there was no other way think about how
the Russos confirmed that the threat is
even greater and it does still seem like
Thanos is gonna be one of the main
villains if not the main villain but
there'll be other problems that are
caused because of all these snaps think
of that movie Groundhog Day in all the
chaos that was caused while he was
trying to figure out what he was really
supposed to do to break the cycle so you
have the idea of the Avengers in all
these disparate places in their lives
they're all broken apart the correct
path is for them to come together you
have the idea of Captain Marvel who's an
x factor as well as the x factor of
ant-man with quantum energy just
remember though when you're thinking
about all these crazy scenarios for
Avengers 4 that it's still gonna be a
Disney movie released for a mass
audience so even though it sounds like
it could get really crazy and really
complicated by the time they edit it
down to the final runtime it'll make
about as much narrative sense as
Infinity Ward did so if you feel like
that was simple enough to follow it'll
be the same scenario with Avengers 4 the
real payoff is is that you know that the
Avengers will eventually be victorious
and they'll all come together so the
fascination with all this crazy multiple
universes quantum energy and upgraded
power sets weapons costumes is really
just the icing on the cake just remember
like the really simple idea is that they
have to break the cycle come together
the subtext of all that as the writer
implies though is that dr. Strange's
plan thanassis plan in the avengers
plans for fixing everything or way more
complicated than what will wind up
seeing on screen which is where all
these cool art books come in because
they give you those details because it
makes the movies seem that much cooler
number 2 moving into Captain Marvel
territory websites are reporting that
the movie is set during 1995 the
evidence that they're providing is that
this is coming from a Japanese language
official Disney website so if it's
coming from one of Disney's own websites
I'm more inclined to believe it so 1995
sounds like a pretty solid bet smack dab
in the middle of the 90s if we get any
more information about what's going on
with the timeline and how that ties into
other movies I will totally do a video
about it but number one you may have
heard the Disney CEO did a big earnings
call where he revealed details about
phase four and all these Avengers force
spin-off projects like the Loki series
The Scarlet Witch envisioned series
Tom Hiddleston recently came out and
confirmed that this is the little teaser
that he tweeted out recently low-key
more stories to tell more mischief to
make more to come
during that earnings call where the
Disney CEO was talking about this TV
show he did imply that Disney was
planning on launching the service with
this along with that Mandalorian Star
Wars TV series Sebastian Stan was also
on Kimmel last night talking about his
Winter Soldier Falcon TV series because
Jimmy Kimmel is like are you gonna
become Captain America on this TV series
so here's just a cut-down version of
that but now there is talk that your
character and the Falcon will have a
show a show together called Miami Vice
[Applause]
that would be great if that's the angle
they do it you guys are in Miami you
know in the comic books Bucky becomes
Captain America yeah yeah has that been
discussed with you at all on any kind of
a level no it does not not really no
it's usually like you know it's like a
dream you know it just sort of people
might mention something but it's never
go that way his answer there almost
seems like he's confirming that he's not
gonna become Captain America and they're
just gonna do Winter Soldier Falcon
stuff on this new TV series they even
confirmed that there's another Star Wars
live-action TV series it'll be a rogue
one prequel with casseon z' character
and a probably a whole bunch of other
characters that you saw during row 1 if
we get any more details about that I
will totally make videos but it sounds
like they're gonna start shooting this
Loki series relatively soon if they plan
on releasing it by the end of next year
we might even get a first trailer for
that at Comic Con next summer there's a
lot of Comic Con stuff that they'll have
to talk about x-men Fantastic Four all
these new TV series it's gonna be crazy
let me know in the comments though if
Thanos is still going to be the main
villain of Avengers 4 what do you think
this greater threat is that they keep
talking about why are the stakes higher
I'll be doing more videos about those
alternate infinity war endings and
deleted scenes coming soon leave your
requests in the comments below
congratulations Steven Velazquez you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details click here for that
Loki infinity war deleted scene and all
turn it ending and click here for that
brand-new spider-man into the
spider-verse
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]